minister in the callao the control of
hotel gangs in a few batteries by
yangzhou jan williams and phil batteries
ehart by the big mafia voices in
Constant conflict golf and the police
and travel yangtsé
upon being admitted winfrey members one
sight gang
now in this to bands in transgression
sites will admit howard stringer
facilitated by guzmán recreativo
gates that live
who the
can cast you
to kill
coca and marijuana
because because if you do drugs and you do
this then your brain is going to win you
the conscience will win you
he convinced him when he was 15
start to walk like batteries well
show me now let's enjoy it motorbike
we also carry 18 I want you to
mates with three friends
without thinking about the first one I failed
fatecha by conscience but a
second third you liked coin plate and
I continue forward this stage gives me
eat to see my family the only thing that
I can say good I can tell you with
this pipe
I develop myself with this pipe
we do what we do, nothing more
we also put all those who stole
all the bananas we put the coin by
a trap with a good head will
will run between 34 lucas and nothing else and
how much in the minimums that is now and
then the only thing you have to do
is to download you nothing else always on a motorcycle
has a motorcycle has to be with a rod
the cane not only enter here nothing happens
and traffic does not run however
of isoft motorcycles by criminal
activities we manufacture uruguay dspytm
Peru from the definitive ministry
wiesel and proposal what wef orbit you
mail are travel in on the same motorbike
normally the police take it as
we call it the first thing
you do
there has to be a female police
the cops go to the men but
we also have women who
they support us other weapons
what is the link between the port the
cocaine trafficking of cocaine and the
hired killer for example an example I'm going
to give a little
container driver a cut the
quiet that does not want to cover your money
to move drugs from us that
we do not touch the ground and we grab
and we put another driver who wants sheet metal
your silver and if you do not want to plate your silver
equal silver lead the floor goes
the callao and esport when west coast
the sun of america considered in that
occur with beams lost software
killing the world
after colombia is no surprises de
antinarcotics police mannatech point a
thousand internal sports
In general, the work of a worker
port of Callao is a job of
high risk true mafias try to
capture these workers
can perform different mechanisms
to coerce the
in 2015 according to the
statistics we have 11 homicides
murders carried out by assassins and
dedicated to drug trafficking not
sent with colonizations
criminals who were rooted in the
cut
in 2016 we have seven cases in the
year 2017 none has been presented
every time it has managed to disrupt
large organizations dedicated to
drug trafficking
drug walk has installed here this
scanner to be able to check the interior
of the containers and to the day more or less
how many can review
an average of 70 to 80 containers
callao port mustang diaries estimated
to million containers that give them your
present of the current inspector by
anti-narcotics police
and this container that shows
[Applause]
to do the parts
of the door
of an orange but lower
how much has happened to you that you have
found suspicious images that has
result being cocaine decays
twice in the last times
the donuts have the authority to be able
carry out the interventions at sea and
we do it together with the navy and
Helping
they forbid me neivis maine volvéis is what
that was sport in designs in eivissa
they are golden involved in the fight
against drunk traffic in an criminal
quiet path of useful interventions
with the counter narcotex police
from operation taking place to day
involved about the universe and start
green their pizzas bowls in looking for
people
last week deivid highlights polo people the
wanted by illicit small spot index
Sports difficult to contain
-you paper teagle interest to be
with drivers world times vacation
English the gang's example eduardo las
narco drivers experience drivers by
stadium charges before andersen
effective hold for peace of drug tura
Julian accomplices in your team you leave
redil sports
about the narco drivers software and well
capture of whit anderson seeds
kilos of cocaine working loads
with this we have received information
we still do not have exact data but it's going
have an infection of some cases of
some boats
[Music]
Watson piccolo be visible to our
contained and saved inspector has been
lived up to place to store drugs for
the answer charges
but no
father all over the world
and not
that plate that raised it and a meter
inspection
looking for drugs janderson lovers
Kisses
the leaf dish porte one of the ibex is
israel what has inferred a feat
iguana green authorities is enough to have
a handle that says I'm in Lima
together with all is its abstention yes
the constancy
Wendys bank melon student in
alcohol and 6-4 in the school of this blog
the huffington post structured kate
to upload
today the police and mobile this week
rock show granada location of narcotics
William Levy 19 d
like a week of cocaine
marijuana 133 kilograms of liver
cocaine 208 kilograms
the day of cocaine with other substances
85 kilograms in total of all
drugs 2 755 grams
According to police officers
take the summercase jones wikileaks and their
shipments to your first chance
here which is this means of
golf for the killers may the wait for me
markets in order to satisfied erin
cuisine demand
my new back in the notorious will come out
are
frame is action to prevent family
woldegiorgis neural pinter
I repeat I will never die is always going to
be at the heart of the others
authorities regarding the killing pepito
is legitimate self defense solís
Relatives and friends believe that the
states steel mixtura be 100% useful
and monsters the time justice here and
balls division
continuous frame and without alternative fortune
his balance for his community what I
I want to leave at least there in my
brothers who also in this novel
delinquency
an association where for them this
if they do not have work they do not have
to take home anything that
it remains of me to bring back to the streets
to steal or do other bad things
God
of this association are not only two
whereabouts someday they become 67
for them where where they work there 200
300 young people who were engaged in things
bad and now they are engaged in work and
with that they can feed and take out
forward to your family not
[Music]
you know that my in my area
the time to respond is at night to
times assaults occur we give him
We give security the safety of
people economically or with only
52 soles I leave you at your door and it's
sure and I want more tomorrow
go ahead the newspapers or the people outside
Callao speak very well of Callao
change fell change
of local polis del callao out of
color in the article party football
match is in this thymus blocks
chinchón of health out of words and
opportunity for him to make a wish book
and skills green bay
very pretty
and here so good a neighbor's cat
of the town of Salta colonia de Callao
peru ok with the national police of peru
working sure to unite all the
police with the community to get the
that we are not new and we have assumed a
challenge the quiet is a place that nobody
Wants to come
just the majority are armed to the channel
with traffic abound the passes strong
drug
and always here are the heads
it is the root of everything
today holguin
the local caps of locations
in one big game brains soccer is
despaired and marked that they are times and you
Sun master of genre the dances of
witten city 6 in the callao
the apprentice football match between
cause local may not show great of
color and its effect on the callao interfax
the English division presents the
report is the painter of the balance
the web is Monday so close that it does not
contains as tripers minds and part
edwin google the callao steel rap and
the culture the violence and drug virus
standard order it's like law of the sport city
the iniap is for future in and tension and
disappointing text amplists
practicable form of stories of same
drying ambition of our sensitive
a supply you were nou guardiola you said
fit next